يعلم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول ل واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ان الوجيز في كتاب الطهاره
اداب الخلاء
يقول ويجب الاستنزاه من البول
‏and isigat
that
a person
safeg himself
when when using the rest
that they do not
soil theirothingally
when urinating and when he mentions
urina the reason for this is because
this
يقول فعن ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مر بقبرين فقال
انهما ليعذبان وما يعذبان في كبير
وما يعذبان في كبير يعني في ظنهما
يعني لم يلقي
بالا لهذا الامر
اي او لهذين الامرين العظيمين عند الله
وتحسبوه هينا وهو عند الله عظيم
فيقول وما يعذبان في كبير يعني عند الناس
ليس بكبير ليس بامر يستعظمه الناس لكن
الله عز وجل يستعظمه اما احدهما فكان لا
يست يستنزه من بوله
واما الاخر فكان يمشي بين الناس بالنميمه
الحديث في الصحيحين ما هي النميمه النميمه
نقل الاخبار بين الناس على وجه الافساد
العلماء يعرفون النميمه
بانها نقل الاخبار
بين الناس على وجه الافساد
نعم so ابن عباس narrates that prop that
the propet
once passed by two graves, two men in
their graves. And he commented to his
companions that were with him, "These
two men in their graves are being
tortured. They are not being tortured
for something that is considered to
be a very big deal with people. But with
Allah, it is a b deal.
‏The first of the two would relieve
himself and not safegard himself from
getting urine on his clothing.
And the second of the two would carry
tails between people. ‏So the two things
are mentioned here
one has to do with something between him
and Allah and that is that when he would
himself
the would come back on hisothing he
wouldn't really b with it he wouldn't
clean it and he was sloppy when he would
relieve himself
and this inil has a domino effect what
is the domino effect well
‏invidates a person's prayer
and not only is something that when a
person he has you know
of prayers invalidated
but a person
is not
suceptable
and the
الصلاه تنهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر
الصلاه الصلاه المقبوله
الصلاه المقبوله الصلاه الصحيحه عند الله
هو يقول الصلاه ان الصلاه مش ان صلاه
يعني حي الله صلاه لا صلاه معينه التي
ارادها الله في هذه الايه ان الصلاه للعهد
الذهني
فالمقصود هنا ان هذه الصلاه الصحيحه هي
التي تنهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر واما الصلاه
الباطله او الناقصه فانها ناقصه في
فعاليتها
على حسب نقصان
صحه الصلاه
الله
صلاه
صلاه صلاه صلاه
الله
صلاه
‏deficient will be likewise deficient
and a person whose prayer is deficient
his deigion
his deficient
his very
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما رايت من ناقصات
عقل ودين كاحداكن
فسالنا عن نقصان الدين فقال
فانها تحيض ويمر عليها ايام لا تصلي ولا
لا تصوم ولا تصلي
هل هذا من جراء فعلها؟ لا هذا الشيء جبلها
الله سبحانه وتعالى عليه لكن نقصان
ال الصلوات ونقصان
يعني الصلوات المفروضه فانها تستلزم نقصان
في
‏And so we understand from this that a
person
spattering himself with when he relieves
himself is a major sin in Islam. A major
sin what does that mean a major sin? Who
the definition of a major sin? A major
sin.
‏Masallah a ma sin isibit
act that attach to a particular
punishment. So here particular
punishment is punishment in one's grave
flames and torture and such in a
person's grave.
واما الاخر فكان يمشي بين الناس بالنميمه
[Silence]
‏con
not
someone
a go and tell them what was
‏are wor of the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
are wor of
when people areilty of it is a cri
against our
is a cri against our brotherh our
commity
do they show
‏and ta
and hoof feet. Do they breathe fire and
smoke? No. They show up and tell you,
listen, I I don't usually talk about
this stuff. I don't care what people do.
I don't getting involved. But, you
know, I just want to let you know I
heard, but this is just for you. I don't
this stuff. I don't like,
you know, gossip and rumors and stuff.
‏I'm above that. I'm in the stratosphere
everybody else is down here. So I don't
get involved in that. When you hear an
opener that, someone begins talking
that. They are telling you exactly
who they are with their denials of who
they are. It is haram to listen to this
kind of thing. حم
un
advised right this is extremely
destructive thing and people talk right
we it is haram for us to speak ill of
someone who not present without
necessity
but does it happen yes people make
mistakes
‏So what do we do? Do we inflame that
mistake and carry it and make it twice
as bad? Of course not. We hide it. We
each other's mistakes and we spread each
other's good other.
وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا